if you were gonna sum up the season with
one word what would you say it should go
one word yeah it's a joke because
there's just so much stuff happening
[Music]
that was so trashy I want to get into
some of your co-stars they have some
props here okay I have give them la la
or give them the finger I love this I'm
gonna hand this to you okay I'm just
gonna go down a list of cast members
people you work with I like this picture
of me that's your official head shot
this year oh I like it
and you just say whether you give them a
llama I give them the finger okay we'll
start with the queen bee Lisa always I
love her five stars for Lisa Vanderpump
you show some respect
Jax oh I really like him this season hi
let's not this season just in general my
life he's like pretty badass we talk
frequently me him Jax and my man we
keeps it on the real 24/7 like group
chatting yes okay you get to give them
Lala
Britney I feel like no one's ever given
Britney the finger she's so kind so kind
and what's crazy about it is she's so
kind and still fun to watch on TV yes
right a rare combo I love my little
Kentucky muffin Stassi
I feel like I'm giving everybody la la
well I kind of stacked the deck Ennis oh
you did okay so the fingers are coming
up not that anyone's counting scheana
okay
can we do both yeah because we have that
friendship where we like we've been
friends from the jump
so we keep it real that's what I was
wondering I was like I feel like scheana
could go either way either way I mean we
don't beat around the bush with our
friends and with Ariana
the babe yeah yeah I just like chicks
that are very just real on the sleeve
you'll you'll watch our our friendship
take a lot of different turns this
season which I like that's relationships
for you
Sandoval's dee dee mostly cuz he knows
how to dance like a champion and then
schwartzie has anyone ever give him in
short I was gonna say probably not he's
the best
probably just Katy every once in a while
you don't let me do anything I do what I
want yeah that's okay but has that
happens when you're in a relationship
Katy I love her too how crazy you would
have never ambulance yeah this is if I
we played this game two years ago not a
different answer not happening
family person I would have gotten this
is James and Kristen can we do both for
hurts aliens yeah guess sometimes I'm
like you know she's she's Kristen always
brings it in the fourth quarter
traffic James
a big one a big one yeah only this no
one can replace James Kennedy baby I
know it seems like James and Raquel
might disappear midseason or something
the way everybody is reacting to them do
they survive the whole year um they're
not on a lot of like when we have
functions with all of us there's not
many people that care for him so no
cannot invite it to a lot of the fun
that we do pardon my french and then I
threw this one in Philly this season
yeah yeah what happens
oh gosh you guys I like she just says a
lot of stupid stuff that when you say
stupid stuff you have to pay I'm telling
you season seven is lit and it like you
can't describe it any other way
[Music]
[Applause]
you